Anne Blum, thank you so much
for being on my show.
How are you?
Thank you so much for having me.
I'm delighted to be here.
I'm great.
Six months into quarantine,
but still surviving. I can't complain.
How are you?
So, I'm doing fine.
But I see only one plant.
And you said you have a hundred plants
in your apartment and three trees, right?
Yes. This is one of the trees.
Most of the plants are downstairs.
It's hard to carry them up the stairs.
Of course. Of course.
In my living room,
I've basically turned it into a greenhouse
During quarantine,
I've had a lot of free time.
So, I've been doing gardening indoors
because I don't have any
outdoor space, unfortunately.
And also painting.
I love it.
Okay. So, I've been hearing that a lot.
A lot of people have been taking up
botanics and gardening lately.
So, it's definitely very interesting.
I figure if you can't go outside,
might as well bring the outside in.
100%. 100%.
So, Anne, I mean,
it's a really fascinating journey
that you've had.
And I'm very excited
to hear about the insights
that you've gained along the years
from running two accelerators in New York.
One of them the German accelerator,
another one Ellis.
Moving on to early stage venture capital
helping European and Israeli startups
break into the US market
with Angular ventures
as the head of platform.
But you started out in corporate.
You started out
in mobile developer outreach
for Facebook, right?
Well, actually, my first job ever
after college was at Goldman.
As HR.
Yeah, HR. So, that was a great start.
I really enjoyed starting my career
at a large company,
especially Goldman.
It's a fantastic life's work
and I got to meet and work
with some really incredible smart people.
100%. So, I have to ask
the German accelerator.
Like I mentioned, I was looking forever
for what is the name
of the German accelerator.
And you just helped me
clarify a second ago.
But please clarify
for everybody watching this.
So, the German accelerators
the name is German accelerator.
Which is probably the most German way
to come up with an accelerator name.
You have no idea how many times
when I worked there, people would be like,
"What's the name
of the German accelerator?"
I'm like, "The German accelerator."
I'm sure. I'm sure.
So, it's always like it's capital now.
It works with title [--]
and thought through it.
The program is doing quite well.
Whatever makes people talk about it
the more obviously works.
But you're not from Germany.
You're from France originally, right?
So, my dad's American.
He's a Jew from the Bronx.
And then, my mom was from Paris.
So, I basically spent,
I was born in London,
then lived in Paris for a bit.
And when I was three, I moved to New York.
Still spending my summers in France,
typically in Paris or the south,
specifically Basque Country.
And then in New York,
I grew up in Westchester.
I went to the French American school.
So, I still speak French
and try to keep that connection alive.
But I'm very Americanized in my culture.
No. I don't speak German,
not German at all.
Fortunately, that wasn't a prerequisite
to working at the German accelerator.
How do you go from HR at Goldman Sachs
to mobile developer outreach
at Facebook
to running two accelerators
at the same time in New York?
It's a great question.
I would love to say that
I had this big grand plan for my career.
I'll do this too and then I'll do that.
No. Not at all.
This is not planned. It just happened.
And don't get me wrong,
I'm very happy with the outcome of it.
But the mindset I had
when I started my career was,
or at least my first job at Goldman was
I love this, this is fantastic,
I'm supporting.
Basically my role there was
in learning and development
and helping the 9,000 plus engineers
that worked at Goldman
know everything they needed to know
from technical side,
all the way to soft skills.
And I was there for
about a year and a half.
And I thought I was going to be a lifer.
Like, I really jive
with the corporate culture.
My dad had worked there for a long time.
And I think especially,
coming straight from college,
being in a part of the whole,
like most classes and training programs.
It is just a lot of fun.
And then, I knew ultimately
I didn't want to be in HR long term.
It just wasn't exactly,
I really enjoyed it
but I knew that I didn't want
to make a career in that.
Now, when you say HR, just to clarify,
because there's a lot of
different facets in HR,
so what specifically
were you working on within Goldman Sachs?
So, learning and development.
And I was specifically
on the Goldman Sachs University
at technology training.
So that I was very lucky and that
I was placed on the tech team.
Because you get accepted and then you go
to Goldman Sachs University
and they have different teams aligned
to the different divisions.
And most people wanted to be
on the IT team
or security is like the sexy teams.
And I was like, they put me on tech.
This is like I find interesting,
I want to be with my techies.
And back then, I think,
especially in New York, Tech was cool.
And I was very lucky
that I got this my team.
I got to meet a ton
of really great engineers
and work with them.
And also happened to fall
into this tech world,
which I fell in love with.
And after working with engineers
for a while, I realized,
Okay, if I'm really meant into this tech scene,
how can I get more into this.
And the logical conclusion was
go to a tech company.
And one of my best friends from Cornell,
she was at Facebook
working on the FB startup program.
So, she pulled me in.
It happened very quickly.
And I joined at the end of 2015.
And it was an amazing experience.
I mean it was a very small team.
We were three people
and we were running a program
with at the time over 12,000 startups
all around the world.
So, it was a very much scaled program.
But we were able to support them
in a scaled manner
to events all around the world,
give them benefits,
mentorship from Facebook, community, etc.
So, you're saying that there wasn't
this grand plan, but I do see a pattern.
I am working on a pattern here
that you're starting out in finance,
but you're gravitating towards tech
and then you find yourself
helping 12,000 startups within Facebook.
So, it is now very logical
as to how you went
to create two accelerators
and then you end up helping leverage
the portfolio companies
for an early stage venture capital fund
like Angular Ventures.
Absolutely.
So, I will say that
when I was still in school
and I didn't know what I want to do,
I just knew that I wanted to have
a positive impact, whatever it was
that I was doing.
And then fell into the tech world
and then ended up working
with startups at Facebook.
And that's when I knew,
Okay, I fell in love with startup Game
and this is what I wanted to do
for the rest of my life.
To be supporting startups,
hopefully helping them
achieve their goals.
And ideally, I would love to be involved
with building the next Google
or other big tech company.
Right.
And it was a really awesome experience,
I think, especially being in Silicon Valley
I moved there in 2015,
Facebook was growing
incredibly quickly at the time.
There is nothing quite like it.
I will say from a social perspective,
moving from downtown Manhattan
to Menlo Park, it was like it.
I'm sure.
It was a bit of a change.
But it was an incredibly exciting experience
and one that I was very fortunate
to be a part of.
And I was on the platform
partnerships team.
And the thing with Facebook is
things change really quickly
from one day to the next.
So, after about a year and a half
working there, I knew that
I wanted to come back to the East Coast.
Most of my family and friends are here.
And I also saw
that the New York City tech scene
was starting to really come into its own.
And I wanted to be a part of that
because there's something here
and I miss the New York energy.
And there's something really special
about New York, so, I came back.
And I did something it's like
I feel like most people
would discourage doing it,
but I thought it was fantastic,
is after working at Goldman and Facebook,
I was tired.
Both were very intense jobs,
working late night every night,
working almost weekends.
And I was like, "I need a break."
So, you go and you ran two accelerator
at the same time.
It makes sense.
Well, before that,
I took six months off
to travel the world.
I went to Israel for the first time,
which is amazing.
And I went to a bunch of other places.
And I thought like
being somewhat of a workaholic.
I thought I would be so bored
during my time off
and that was not at all the case.
I was happy until it last.
I was like, I could do this
for a couple of years. This is great.
A couple of years.
Then you throw yourself again
into this environment.
I'd love to understand a little bit better
about your insights from
running those two accelerators.
Specifically this whole notion
of breaking into the US market.
I think it's something
that's extremely fascinating
both for startups that are starting out
in the US market,
but also for a lot of my friends
around Europe and Israel
who are running their companies.
A lot of them are considering
when to relocate.
I'm very very good friends
with Shuly and Gil from UpWest
and Yair, a guy from Fusion LA,
and so there's a lot of talk about
how to help outside companies
break into the US market.
And I'd love to hear a little bit
about your insight from doing that,
both from the accelerator
and then we'll transition also
into your  work with Angular Ventures.
Of course. Yeah.
So, when I came back to New York,
I started working
at the German accelerator.
And that program was about
bringing German startups to the US market.
I think that Germany
was ahead of the game.
There is actually a program
sponsored by the German government.
So, it's great for the startups.
Zero equity, zero fees.
Yeah. Which is very special.
And I think Germany rightfully realized
that the way to long term
grow their economy was really investing
in their startups.
And a big part of that investment
is helping them come to the US.
I think that this is something
that's especially true
for companies that are B2B,
especially enterprise.
Just because so many
of the largest companies
are based in the US.
And being able to meet with them
and get their feedback
and bring them on as design partners
is so vitally important.
So, that program,
I ran that program
as a program manager for two years.
And then, also saw that
there was a big appetite for startups
who wanted to come to the US
from other parts of the world.
I know Israel that's been so ingrained
in the Israeli ecosystem for so long
that for Israelis,
it's like obviously, this is a no brainer.
But for a lot of other countries,
it was less obvious.
I think, too, for startups
let's say from France
or from Italy or Germany,
there can be that fallacy of like,
my market is big enough, right?
I can go to the top French companies
and grow it through there.
But ultimately, you tap out
of your market really quickly.
And by the time you're like,
okay, I conquer the French market
now it's time to go to the US,
you could have a competitor here
that's already taken over the market
and you might be put
at a serious disadvantage.
So, we saw that there was this need.
So, I co-founded Ellis Accelerator
and we ran three different cohorts
through that program.
And that was all about bringing companies
from all around the world to the US.
And it worked pretty well.
I'd say that the biggest reasons
for startups to think about
coming to the US and obviously things,
the way you do that now with covid
is a bit different
than the way you did it before.
But the reasons are still
fundamentally the same sales acceleration.
So, we've actually done a bit of research
and for more than 80% of startups
that come to the US,
their sales drastically increased after.
Really? 80%?
83%. Yes.
83%. That's wow.
Yeah. And then also,
it's much easier to fundraise, right?
There is a lot of investors in the US,
there's a lot of money flowing.
And so, for about 40% of the startups
that came here,
they had an easier process fundraising.
But I do have to ask, Anne,
because obviously there is this
the mindset shift is a challenge
on its own, right?
So, providing that accessibility
into the American mindset
and actually making that move
of transitioning the business
towards the US market,
but what other challenges did you notice?
Whether it's through
the German accelerator or else,
what are some of the common challenges
that the companies
or early stage companies face
as they come to the US?
And they're saying like,
wow, this is something either we didn't expect
or, wow this is like a hurdle that we're facing
along with a lot of other newcomers here.
I think there's a lot of challenges.
Some of them are foreseen
some of them are not.
I would say an interesting thing,
especially I'm based in New York,
a lot of founders they come here
and they're just blown away
by how expensive everything is, right?
It's like you come here,
[--]
everything is expensive.
And so, I would say going into it,
be prepared to make an investment
because there will be
a lot of upfront costs.
So, that's one thing.
It's a big investment
just from a time perspective
and also a capital perspective.
I would say managing the culture
is quite difficult
when you now have a team
in the US, in Israel.
Time makes it challenging to me
when you're hiring American employees,
the culture, there can be some clash
where people,
you both speak in English
but you may still not be able
to understand what the other person
is saying implicitly.
And then I would say to another track
that a lot of startups I see fall into
is hiring the wrong people.
You see this especially with sales people.
American sales people are really good
at selling themselves.
And especially for someone
coming from outside the US,
that you hear them
and they talk about their sales experience
and it's like, it's perfect.
This person is going to grow
our sales funnel tremendously.
And then a couple months down the line,
it doesn't work.
I would honestly say that most times,
the initial sales people
don't end up working out.
So, the advice I'd give there is
be very very careful
who you bring on to the team.
Hire slow and if they don't work out,
like if you're even thinking
about letting someone go, then go.
Right.
Hire slow, fire fast.
Exactly.
And I think that holds true
both domestically
and when you're in the US.
But especially because
salaries are more expensive here.
It can be very costly to keep someone on
if they're not bringing in real revenue.
100%. 100%
And I want to make sure
we also have enough time
to talk about Angular Ventures
because I think that
being head of platform
for an early stage fund,
the mission is very clear.
And it's something
that I really resonate to
an it's not too far off
from what you were doing
with the two other accelerator's.
But now you're doing it
with the head of the VC
and you're doing it
with portfolio companies
that you have a stake in, right?
So, it's no longer just companies
that are coming in and they're asking
for your help, but you actually,
you have a stake in the game.
Talk to me a little bit about
what Angular Ventures is
and what is your specific role
within that fund
that is bridging the gap between
basically the whole world?
Absolutely.
So, basically, Angular Ventures
is an early stage fund that invests
in startups from Europe and Israel.
We typically do checks from anywhere
from 200,000 to 1.5 million.
We do lead, we do follow on.
Our focus is deep tech enterprise.
About half of our portfolio currently
is Israeli based or Israeli founders,
and the other half is
spread out throughout Europe.
And I met Gil Dibner,
the partner of the fund,
about a year before the fund
officially closed for fund one.
And I was always intrigued
by venture capital.
I wasn't necessarily pursuing it
because I was happy
in the accelerator world.
But I was really interested
with what Gil was doing.
His track record is really impressive,
having four out of 30 investments
that he's made have become unicorns.
And then the idea of working in,
because the downside with working
in the accelerator world is you're working
with these companies super intensely
for three months.
And then, it's like little birds.
they fly away and they go
do their own thing.
And yeah, you obviously still keep in touch.
But it's not the same level of work.
Whereas in the VC world,
and this was something
that really appealed to me is that
you can have this long term relationship
with these founders, at the end
and at the absolute earliest stage,
we'll do checks
with someone with just an idea.
We like getting in very very early
and help them build their company
from the ground up.
And then work with them
for 10 years plus maybe.
And so, that was
incredibly appealing to me.
And then also the idea,
having founded my own company before.
I love the idea of
being the first platform hire
and building the platform up
from the ground up.
And fortunately, I would say that Gil,
the partner of the fund,
he is very dedicated to working
with the portfolio companies as well.
So, he spends about half his time
working with existing companies
and the other half obviously,
working on a deal flow
and evaluating the opportunities.
Of course that shifts
with the covid epidemic,
I'm sorry, the covid pandemic.
Like many other VC's
we were primarily focused
on our own portfolio even though
we were still doing deals actively.
But just making sure that the portfolio
will survive and thrive
during this time.
Of course.
So, we've built some
few really exciting things
on the platform side.
Ultimately, our goal is to be supportive
of our founders and their startups
and ensure that they have
all the resources and connections
they need in order to be successful.
So, I would say some of the most
more interesting or impactful things
that we offer the portfolio companies
are we have about
a dozen advisory partners,
which include the two unicorn founders
from JFrog and SiSense.
And we also have subject matter experts
from branding, marketing, sales, etc.
So, whenever any of our
portfolio companies have a need
on one of these key areas
we'll pair them
with these advisory partners
and then they work long-term together.
So, oftentimes working together
for a year or more.
So, it's a really deep relationship.
We also want to focus on things
that really move the needle
and especially working
with enterprise startups.
The contract sizes for customers
can be so big that if we can help them
get one new client, we've done our job.
So, we do focus a lot
on bridging the corporates in our network
with these portfolio companies
in order to see if there is
any possibility for design partnerships
or for the corporates potential
to become customers ultimately.
We've done a few
really interesting research reports.
So, at the start of the pandemic,
we looked at how covid
was impacting startups from,
how many of them
were changing their product
to doing layoffs.
So, what exactly were
the startup founders thinking of
throughout this time.
We just released last week a report
on enterprise deep tech VC
in Europe and Israel.
So, if anyone's interested
in reading that, it's up on Medium.
Definitely encouraged you to check it out.
And then we're right now
working with Index Ventures,
specifically talking or looking
at how Israeli startups
can successfully expand
to the US market, which is, of course,
top of mind for a lot of founders.
100%. So, before we end,
I have to go back and look at your journey
a little bit more realistically,
because you've gone through
so many different experiences.
A lot of them are
in the same line of thought
of how do we work
with early stage companies
to either help them
break into the US market
or continue to scale and grow.
And I'd love to hear from you
some of the insights
that you've gained throughout the years.
If you were to look back
and talk to a young entrepreneur
or a young person that's going into
the tech scene or any scene,
what are some key things
that they should keep in mind
as they go on their career path?
So, basically, what are some creatives?
Right.
Okay. I have quite a few ideas.
A lot of these
I had to learn the hard way.
And now I get to hear them
the easy way.
So, if this helps one person,
hopefully it's worth what the trials
and tribulations I went through.
So, I would say I have five tips
for people who are in their career
and that for me have been quite valuable.
So, the first is storytelling.
Everything at the end of the day
is about how you can create
an interesting and compelling story.
Whether you're in college
trying to land a job,
you have to create a good story
about why what you've done in the past
is relevant for the company
and why you're value added
to the specific company.
Whether you're a founder,
that's creating a story about
why an investor should invest
in your specific company.
I think storytelling is really important.
For me and my career,
I use storytelling
when I was pivoting out of HR
and went to Facebook.
And the way that I focused on it
was rather than focusing on the fact
that I was an HR, it was like, no,
I was running programming for tech.
Which is very relevant
to running a startup program at Facebook.
And then I would say another thing
that's really important is very few things
are worth being the hill to die on.
I've been guilty of this.
What does that mean?
Yeah. So, basically what that means
is don't ruin professional relationships
trying to prove your point, right?
I've been guilty of this at times,
especially early on in my career,
where it's like
you know the right answer
or you think you know the right answer
and you really want to make sure
the team or your company does it that way.
And it can definitely backfire on you
if you're really holding steady on this.
So, what I do now
is say my thoughts
and what I think we should do.
And if leadership wants to do it, awesome,
if not, fine.
Just not getting as personally invested.
I will caveat that by saying
there are some things which are worth
being the hill to die on.
I've personally encountered one of them
and it was literally,
"If we don't do this,
I will walk away from the company."
Like that.
So, it does happen occasionally,
but I think ultimately be very mindful
of not ruining your relationships.
Because your teammates,
you have to work with them.
This project is going to be over
at some point soon.
But the teammates, if you're working
at this company for years,
you have to continue working with them.
So, I think it's really important
to have positive relationships with them.
I have to say regarding that point,
it's so interesting.
I remember, I often reflect back
to my officers academy training,
and I remember that
one of my commanders there,
she give us a talk about our values
and the things that we are
really passionate about.
And especially in a military setting,
it's often a very interesting balance
between the things that you believe in,
the things that the system believes in,
at the end, you know your role
within an organization.
And it's perhaps it's accelerated
within a military organization
because the thing you're working towards
is different than just
monetary value for the company.
But one of the things she told us is that,
you really have one chance
within an organization to choose something
that is worth fighting for,
Enough that you're saying,
"I'm putting my keys down
and if this is not happening,
I'm walking away."
But you only get to do that once, really.
Because the second time,
and the third time is
it doesn't really work.
So, I definitely,
I haven't used that card yet
in any organization.
But I definitely see.
Anne, 20 minutes go by so fast
and obviously,
there are so many more things
that I can learn from.
But before we leave,
I have to ask you for three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Yeah, absolutely.
So, I would say
if I had to use three words
to describe myself,
the first is being determined.
So, if I got an idea in my head,
whether it's work or in my personal life,
it will happen.
Like come hell or high water,
I will make it happen.
And so that's it.
Career wise, it's been pretty helpful.
And then I would say,
I tend to be pretty resilient.
There's been a number of times
where I had to face things
that are pretty challenging.
The few times where I had
to completely start from scratch.
When I moved back to New York
after leaving Facebook
I didn't have an apartment,
I was staying at my friend's place,
I didn't have a job,
so completely rebuilding my life
from scratch.
I think it takes a lot of resiliency
to do that and do it well.
And I think a lot of people right now,
everyone needs to be resilient
going through what we're going through
and managing and then
doing it so successfully.
So, I think that
that's a really important skill to have.
And then lastly, I would say kindness.
There's that famous line that goes,
nice guys finish last.
And I think that is absolutely not true.
I think in the short term,
being Machiavellian can pay off.
But long term, it 100% does not pay off
because people will learn that about you
and then they just will not want
to work with you.
So, I think being kind
both personal life and professional life
is 100% the right way.
And it's worked really well for me.
Anne, thank you very very much.
Thanks for being so generous
with your time and for all the inspiration
and insights through all of this.
It was really wonderful.
I had a great time.
Thank you so much for having me.
This is an absolute pleasure.
Of course. Take care.
Stay safe and healthy.
Bye.